et pour en parler nous sommes avec
halima wang noc économiste ancien député
au parlement européen bonsoir immanente
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur air
france ça y est c'est plié
selon vous cette réforme des retraites
on est en plein coup d'état permanent
après les ordonnances qui ont marqué
l'arrivée au pouvoir de ce gouvernement
dans les ordonnances sur sur le droit du
travail
là on passe en force alors que le
gouvernement lui-même avait refilé
permettez moi l'expression de
l'expression la patate chaude aux
partenaires sociaux en mimant une
conférence sur le financement
et bien cette conférence sur le riz dure
encore a priori elle et elle est
enterrée par le quarantenaire toi il
n'ya plus rien à négocier
fermez le ban et à rien n'a rien à dire
circulez et les syndicats ont très bien
compris fo puis la cgt son parti la cfdt
se pose la question de savoir si elle va
rester donc le dialogue social est mort
et enterré dans ce pays alors le texte 1
pourrait être poussée de 15 jours
demande le sénat gérard larcher ce qui
permettrait peut-être d'attendre les
conclusions de cette fameuse conférence
de financement est ce que vous pensez
que la porte n'est pas complètement
fermée
non mais il y voter la dent dans la
procédure du 49 3 à partir du moment où
la motion de censure ou les motions de
censure sont rejetés la loi est adoptée
et donc le sénat peut
éventuellement apporter un certain
nombre de modifications mais enfin la
commission mixte armement paritaire
tranchera et c'est c'est l'assemblée qui
enfin c'est le texte du gouvernement qui
passera tout quoi alors il ya beaucoup
de français qui sont inquiets en tout
cas qu'ils savent pas à quoi s'en tenir
il ya un texte qui est votée est ce que
chacun aujourd'hui capable de savoir à
quelle sauce qui va être clairement
manger avec ce texte avait au moins on a
un texte et on sait que en lisant
rigoureusement ce texte que les français
vont en majorité y perdre et oui mais
quel français parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
français justement il ya différentes
catégories et différentes secteurs il y
en a qu une des concessions d'autres
noms voit les avocats qui vont continuer
la grève jusqu'au 25 mars
c'est compliqué ce n'est pas linéaire
tout ça les salariés du privé vont ils
perdre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement n'a toujours pas publié
de deux simulateurs
ils vont y perdre parce qu'à partir du
moment où vous passez sur un calcul sur
sur la carrière entière au lieu des 25
meilleures années
le régime du secteur privé va faire
montre de
de perte du point de vue des pensions
qui vont être versés aux salariés du
privé autre exemple
maintenant qu'on a le texte on sait
mieux qu'elle est là la promesse du
gouvernement de m la retraite minimale à
1000 euros vous savez que c'est un de
leurs arguments de vente que dire il y
aura pas une retraite en dessous de 1000
euros c'est faux pour avoir une retraite
au minimum contributif de 1000 euros il
faudra une carrière complète définis
dans le texte par quarante trois années
alors que cette mesure avait été fait
pour les carrières hachées
il n'y a pas beaucoup de carrières
hachées qui iront jusqu'à quarante trois
années donc ça concernera marginalement
les travailleurs et les travailleuses
victimes de carrières hachées
donc les gens commencent à se rendre
compte que ils ont nous ils ont bel et
bien été été bernés depuis le début et
ce gouvernement aurait dû d'ailleurs
l'assumé je ne comprends pas pourquoi ce
gouvernement qui a eu une réforme qui a
pour objectif de limiter la part des
dépenses affectées aux retraites dans le
pib ne tient pas le discours de la
rigueur jusqu'au bout en disant voilà on
peut pas faire autrement et donc dans ce
cas là vous allez devoir faire des
efforts mais plutôt que de tenir ce
discours là il a fait croire aux
français qu'ils allaient gagner
oui parce que c'est ce que j'allais vous
demandez le gouvernement qui nous est
sûre qui aura pas de retraite en dessous
de 1000 euros ça veut dire quoi que
c'est prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles pardonnez moi l'expression
comment ça se rangeront b soi-même ou
mentir ont offensés quelle est votre
analyse vous le gouvernement savait très
bien qu'elle était quel était son
objectif son objectif c'est de limiter
la part des dépenses affectées en
retraite dans le pays bas 14 % oui d'une
part et deuxièmement le la deuxième
borne qui était qui était fixé c'est de
ne pas alourdir le coût du travail
donc à partir du moment où le rapport
actifs/inactifs se dégradent forcément
vous ajustez soit par la la la la valeur
du point mais comme la valeur du point
de le voir avait promis aux syndicats de
l'indexer soit sur les salaires soit sur
l'inflation mais la seule variable qui
reste c'est naturellement le la durée de
cotisation avec en plus le fait que rond
on va dès le départ m dès le curseur des
retraites très bas puisque la valeur du
point de fixer dès le début et après les
indexer mais la valeur du point au début
ma mise de telle sorte que il y aura il
y aura une baisse des pensions et les
gens sont en train de s'en rendre compte
alors les députés socialistes voulaient
créer des commissions banque est sur les
rotules et les fameuses études d'impact
accompagnant cette réforme demande qui a
été rejetée par l'assemblée nationale
pour quelles raisons selon vous parce
que
les choses auraient été sans doute
criante
une étude d'impact aurait montré que
dans l'état actuel des choses il n'y a
pas de problème de financement des
retraites et que dans l'est les
scénarios qui sont envisagées c'est du
sérieux qui sont envisagés avec des
hypothèses de suppressions d'emplois
dans les services publics et avec une
non compensation des cotisations
sociales et donc tout ça mais tu es sur
le tapis des choses qui sont absolument
impopulaire et le gouvernement peut pas
mettre ça de façon transparente sur la
table à l'heure actuelle vous faites
partie de ces opposants nombreux info
bien le dire à ce projet de réforme des
retraites
aujourd'hui quel est votre état d'esprit
à mr ou résignés vous estimez que vous
avez perdu
en raisonnant à froid on savait dès le
début que ce gouvernement passerait en
force ce serait ce que la lettre envoyée
par il voir philippe aux syndicats les
faits entre voir le fait qu'ils
recouraient à 49,3 en disant voilà les
partenaires s'ils n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord
nous prendrons nos responsabilités mais
les partenaires ne pouvait pas se mettre
d'accord ce ne serait ce que sur le
thème de la pénibilité monsieur roux de
bézieux est intervenue la semaine
dernière dans les médias pour dire que
banon la pénibilité on discute pas là
dessus et la seule la seule concession
qui a fait ses dires abat y aura il
faudra une visite médicale et puis on
verra après quoi pour la série tellement
se moquer d'eux
de la tête des syndicats qui ont un
produit on a promis de de discuter sur
sur la pénibilité alors amer vous savez
en camp quand on fait un peu de
politique
il faut raisonner en fonction des
rapports de force
m aujourd'hui il est où le rapport de le
rapport de force marges de manoeuvre
sont entendez voilà certains
syndicalistes dire mais non non on
continue la une manifestation guerre il
y en aura une
la semaine prochaine enfin en tout cas
l'avenir est ce qui a encore une marge
de manoeuvre de la part des opposants
pour le phare que ce texte entre en
vigueur
le rapport de forces est très
défavorable au mouvement social depuis
depuis une trentaine d'années la bonne
nouvelle c'est que là après l'épisode
des gilet jaune
le mouvement syndical traditionnel est
réapparu en forme et que une convergence
des salariés qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude de 2
de manifester et salariés
traditionnellement organisés du secteur
public qui est le bastion de la défense
des conquêtes sociales et bien ça a
commencé tout ça à se mettre en réseau
entre le n'a pas servi à grand chose
mais non pas sur une réforme quand même
emblématique qui est qui est arrivé
juste après ce second ce gouvernement je
vous le répète avait décidé dès son
arrivée de deux derniers témoins et
l'expression de se payer les syndicats
en procédant par ordonnance est ici en
procédant avec le 49-3 donc il a fait du
tas de chair en voulant défaire les les
dernières poches de résistance syndicale
thatcher avait fait ça avec les mineurs
là ils pensent avoir d'effet peut-être
pas pour de bon mais pour une certaine
durée
la résistance syndicale et il ne
s'adresse pas aux syndicats ils ne
s'adressent pas aux salariés ce
gouvernement il s'adresse
il s'adresse à sa droite le problème du
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est de
conserver le pouvoir en s'adressant à
une fraction de l'électorat qui est
tenté aujourd'hui de se tourner vers le
front national est la vraie porosité
elle n'est pas entre la ddt l'extrême
gauche et front national aujourd'hui la
vraie porosité aller entre les
républicains et le rassemblement
national
c'est ce qui va se jouer dans certaines
villes aux élections municipales c'est
ce qui va jouer aux élections régionales
et
le vrai problème dans les deux ans qui
viennent c'est que les mécontentements
qui ont lu aujourd'hui n'ont pas
débouché politique à gauche et que
malheureusement je suis malheureusement
parce que ma sensibilité de gauche
m'amène à regretter cela l'alternative à
sera du côté du côté de la droite et
l'extrême droite et sur le dossier des
retraites
on peut parier que s'ils reviennent sur
cette réforme là eh bien ils allongent
ans il allonge la durée de cotisation et
mettront la retraite à 65 ans comme le
propose la motion de censure de la
droite et des régions d'écart en tout
cas et je trouve que il était pas
tellement opportun pour les députés
venus de la gauche de voter cette motion
de censure parce qu'il vaut mieux oui
tout à fait absolument merci en tout cas
l'hymne en banque d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france ancien député au
parlement européen